je pense que c'est super que soprano
soient avec nous aujourd'hui c'est la
personnalité préférée des 7-14 ans
soprano des jeunes et on va parler d'un
truc hyper important c'est un jeune
garçon victime d'harcèlement scolaire
qui a vraiment ému les internautes c'est
votre coup de coeur raymond à ça on
voulait absolument vous montrer tous les
jeunes qui nous regarde mon rêve à moi
j'ai vraiment été touché par ce petit
bonhomme qui est qui qui dit qu'il veut
aller rejoindre le bon dieu il a 7 ans
il dit qu'il veut aller rejoindre le bon
dieu sait comment comment on peut
arriver là alors il se sert des outils
d'aujourd'hui et poste une vidéo sur
youtube ça marche du tonnerre la vidéo
elle marche bien c'est pour dénoncer
c'est pour dénoncer toutes ces choses là
mais les gens ont dit il ya des gens
qu'on dit il aurait pas dieu l'a
diffusée lors du maître juste le son moi
j'ai pris une gifle
j'ai pris une vraie gifle l'image est
chargé prix vraiment une vraie gifle et
on peut pas continuer nous à se dire
parce que souvent par an on se dit assez
rien céder mon bijou
non non il faut qu'on arrête de dire ses
démons mijoux c'est très grave moi je te
donne un message petit bonhomme sait
très bien ce que tu as fait c'est très
fort et je vais un peu plus loin juste
rajouter un truc 10 secondes
les parents parler avec vos enfants
parce qu'il ya les gens qui sont les
enfants harcelés mais y'a les harceleurs
et parents je m'adresse aux parents les
vos enfants vous savez pas si ils
harcèlent ou pas dites-leur bien que ça
c'est puni par la loi
le harcèlement et vos enfants quand ils
ont moins de 13 ans c'est vous les
responsables
donc c'est vous qui allez aller au
tribunal poser un rtt donc les parents
parlaient que vos enfants
deezer bien que harcelé ça va faire des
emmerdes à tous alors vous allez voir ce
témoignage on y voit donc à bout ce sont
7 en témoigner qu'il est victime
d'harcèlement scolaires ainsi que son
petit frère je sais que sopra devra agir
là dessus est vraiment la vidéo vous
verrez elle est bouleversante regarder
elle a été vue plus de 500 mille fois en
24 heures garde je suis juste eric g7
depuis l'été dernier un gentil garçon
qui s'appelle le ton kit sont tout le
temps vieillit moment que j'ai envie
qu'ils rejoindre le bon dieu de mourir
on ait marre de ce fait les gars y'a peu
de capitaux les jours j'avais
aujourd'hui et pour toujours
oui
alors c'est vrai que voilà la vidéo elle
est vraiment belle et poignante gilles
chez vous avez des infos oui alors on a
eu avec vos équipes la maman elles
s'appellent sandrine le con que je donne
sa maman parce que c'est elle qui nous a
demandé de le donner elle avait
carrément envie c'est le nom de sa maman
c'est la maman donc il a 50 ans ça fait
un an qu'il est harcelé dans un
établissement privé catholique son
prénom c'est charlie c'est la première
fois qu'on nous donne c'est aussi la
maman qui nous a demandé de le donner
parce qu'elle veut que cette histoire
soit connu donc il s'est fait voler
tapez cracher dessus par trois petits
garçons la directrice est intervenue
elle a appliqué des sanctions mais ça a
continué et ensuite c'est le petit frère
arthur qui s'est fait appel à charles il
a craqué c'est pour ça qu'il a fait
cette vidéo est la mère a envoyé cette
vidéo aux parents des harceleurs
mais c'est une dame jeune fille a vu sa
qui s'est emparée de la vidéo qu'il a
mis sur twitter bravo et sans green way
sandrine la remercie parce que du coup
la vidéo devient virale et tout le monde
connaît cette histoire bouleversante
c'est alors vraiment selon le parisien
l'école ne veux pas parler de l'affairé
directrices déclare tout ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que les autorités
compétentes ont été prévenues et un
membre de la direction poursuit ma
collègue a fait son travail
on ne peut pas dire que nous n'avons
rien fait face à cette situation et
c'est vrai qu'il faut il faut agir vite
vraiment nous ça nous a voilà je vous
dis ça nous a bouleversés ce jeune
garçon et son frère seront avec nous
dans balances ton post la semaine
prochaine sa maman veut on parlait
également parce que c'est très important
et on veut veut que ce jeune garçon
aille mieux alors lui c'est un exemple
mais il y en a plein d'autres
et voilà il faut vraiment vraiment à
voir avec l affaire avant ma mort les
gendarmes ont entendu les garçons
harceleur ils ont déjà entendu les
garçons harceleur ou que ça avance oprah
tu voulais tous les rageux voulait
réagir parce que justement c'est vos
prochaines courses nous envoie un clip
que je fais c'est dans mon album j'ai
fait une chanson qui s'appelle fragile
par rapport à ça parce que c'est un
sujet que je trouve urgent sensible
c'est pas la première fois
lada enfin j'allume la télé je vois le
film de michaël youn avec l'histoire
vraie ça m'a bouleversé
moi j'ai une fille de 12 ans qui rentre
collège donc ça me fait émerger et c'est
pour ça que j'ai fait cette chanson
parce que beaucoup d'associations ne
sont pas entendues viennent me voir me
vois des messages est ce que tu peux
mettre un peu en avance parce que
même les petits qui qui harcèlent eux
aussi ne sont il faut le refaire une
pédagogie et oui comme les enfants qui
sont harcelés c'est ce qu'ils disent
c'est pour ça que c'est important
puisque ont même laissé des messages
qu'il faut mettre en avant la lumière
parce que c'est sensible urgent il ya
des enfants qui peut-être ont un talent
énorme mais juste par peur de se faire
harceler se réduisent leurs talents
d'école et on a vu que ce soit sur
internet aura les coins de laisser des
enfants sont beaucoup touché par ça et
on regarde aujourd'hui on voit mal tiré
par ben 12 ans qui tombe de sentosa
bagarre qui conduit la journée contre
l'as ici aujourd'hui la quatrième est
décédé vers lyon lui fait énorme bisou
plein débit est vraiment et on espère
que ça va aller beaucoup mieux pour lui
et pour son frère est vraiment on pense
on pense fort à la maman